6 14 on your Friday morning you know
what it is not too late for any
Elementary student in Clark County to
enter the Mojave Max emergence contest
in the last week or so the desert
tortoise who lives at the Springs
Preserve has slept through a coyote
prowl by and a bunny hop Vibes
[Music]
yes the two-legged Max mascots got the
moves in a cool hip-hop music video
encouraging all of us to save the
tortoise but as long as the real max is
still snoozing youngsters and their
parents and teachers are encouraged to
stop by mojavemax.com to not only learn
why he's a better spring prognosticator
for the desert and that groundhog back
East but also to enter the contest to
guess the exact date and time that the
elementary students think Max wakes up
and thanks to the get Outdoors Nevada
folks there are some really cool prizes
like laptop computers for the winning
student his or teacher a field trip for
the winning students class to visit the
Springs Preserve meet the real Max and
have a pizza party a full disclosure I
am super proud to have been part of the
Mojave Max education program for more
than 20 years we always want to know
what's cool it's cool you got something
let us know cool at school on the
community tab of our website or email
cool at school at 8newsnow.com I feel
bad for any kid who had guessed that Max
would wake up in the month of February
because that didn't happen but you can
still enter we've talked about this
before what's the latest he's ever woken
up April 17th okay so we got some time I
cannot wait that long Nate for Sunshine
the earliest is is Valentine's Day
February 14th so we've had some warm
februaries before this ain't one of them
this was not a war in February Max is
still snoozing yes